president Trump's new communication
director did not last long and Scarah
Moochie appointed 10 days ago was ousted
yesterday by the president's new chief
of staff retired Marine general John
Kelly has the job of restoring order in
the White House in January at his
confirmation hearing to be Homeland
Security Secretary Kelly talked about
how he likes to run an organization I've
never had a problem speaking truth to
power and I firmly believe that those in
power
deserve full candor and my honest
assessment and recommendations I also
value people that work for me speaking
truth to power major Garrett is at the
White House major is this how general
Kelley plans to run the White House it
is and I will tell you I'll get to some
of the mechanics in a minute but the one
of the most important characteristics
general Kelley brings to this job is
that he can walk into a room and own the
room his physical bearing his sense of
self-confidence his military discipline
why does this matter because for
president Trump that ability matters
almost more than anything else to walk
into a room and own it like the
President believes he does so with that
bearing the president hopes general
Kelley will impose discipline create
focus and make meetings on process the
ones that actually matter and eliminate
the ongoing process here in the White
House of secondary or third level
meetings actually getting back to the
president and bringing a process to a
head
what Kelley wants to do is create the
agenda and the process that amplified
the president's strengths and minimize
his weaknesses major can we expect the
general to be cleaning house here and
and how secure is Steve Bannon who was
attacked by Anthony Skye Moochie in that
New Yorker piece well mooch is out Steve
Bannon is still here so that's one
indication that general Kelley wants to
use a military phrase unit cohesion
people working on the same page now
Steve Bannon has for one example been
pushing a much higher tax income rate
for the wealthy and tax reform the White
House doesn't support that so on policy
he lost that one but that ebbs and flows
in the white house no sense anyone in a
senior position is in jeopardy at least
not right now
major was general Kelly the first choice
among people advising the
I believe he was the first choice
willing to take the job and had those
characteristics the president wanted it
was a three-tiered process will you take
the job do you have what it takes and
I'm will am I willing and ready to get
rid of Reince Priebus all these came
together to bring Kelly where he is now
at general Kelley would refuse the job
earlier not that I'm aware of but the
president was looking for people who
could at the right moment take this job
and he found Kelley and it's important
to point out on this when the first
travel ban was put together that process
from Kelly's point of view at the
Department of Homeland Security was a
disaster he gave his objections directly
the president the second process which
Kelly ran was much more organized and
disciplined that's an example of Kelly's
relationship with this president all
right major Garrett at the White House
major thanks